No waiting room!
We're in!
Nah, this is the classic Scott.
Best collab ever.
30 minutes late, minus one person.
Okay, you can't blame it on me!
I'm not the... I showed up!
I showed up!
You are gonna have to collab!
You told me not to kill you at the time!
I didn't tell you shit!
I woke up!
That is fucked up!
I woke up and I didn't even know which discord I'm going to!
Look, I woke up five minutes before...
No, ten minutes before our collab, but I showed up.
My only job was to show up.
I woke up half an hour before.
Half an hour, that's so much better.
Alright, well you ditto.
Ditto!
What's your excuse?
I like Uta.
You didn't even tell Uta the time of the collab!
I can't wait for Uta to wake up and just flame you.
No!
Boom!
Uta went offline for seven hours ago.
And I don't think she's gonna wake up soon.
Seven hours ago?
That means she's gonna wake up in an hour.
Isn't it 5.30 in Japan?
What do you mean she's gonna wake up?
I don't know!
What do you mean?
What's too sketchy?
What the fuck?
I'm amazing.
What do you mean?
It's 5.30 in Japan!
What do you mean she's gonna wake up?
I messaged her an hour before our collab, but she hasn't replied me yet.
Yeah, one hour is really a lot of time to make sure you show up in time.
That works.
Okay, guys.
Okay, before we say anything more, how is our volume?
How's the volume in everybody's stream?
How's the volume?
Is it okay?
I'm gonna put you guys up a little bit just in case.
Alright, I'm gonna right... oh shit.
I accidentally took a photo of myself.
Oh my god, I'm a mess.
I'm a mess.
Why would you be sorry if it's not your fault, Uto?
Yeah, why would you be sorry if it's not your fault?
Look at me.
Look at my steam timer.
Why do we have to look at you?
Look at me.
I would be like, Uto's not here yet because Ditto forgot to tell her the time.
I'm sorry, Uto.
I'm sorry.
Alright, let's go make some money.
Wait, wait, I'm not ready yet.
I didn't even check if my volume's okay.
What?
We just... you figured it out in midway.
Well, let's go make money.
What do you mean?
Okay, Ditto's a bit low.
Okay, let me... I need to raise up Ditto.
Let me raise up Ditto.
Yes.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna...
raise up the...
I don't even know if my sound guy's alive, too.
Wait, how do we point again?
How do we point?
I don't remember.
Oh, two!
I remember now.
Here, two, two, two, two.
Alright, whose fault is this that we're late?
You have to apologize to Uto.
Yeah, you have to apologize.
Actually, you're right.
You know what?
Ditto's right.
You gotta apologize.
You have to apologize.
Ah, silence.
Wait, we're waiting for crew?
What about Uto?
What about... What about Uto?
I'm going alone.
Wait, I don't know if the volume's okay.
I don't know if the volume's okay.
It's okay.
I think he's okay.
Is it okay?
Is the volume okay, guys?
Is it okay now?
Yes.
It's okay for me.
Wait, what about me?
I'm talking about my stream.
You know, before our stream started... Wait, RPR, where did you go?
Yeah.
RPR, where did you go?
Wait for us, RPR!
RPR, where are you?
Okay, before we started the stream chat, we were talking about, you know, the whole it's RPR's fault and the lore behind it.
It only had... That whole thing started from one stream that RPR wasn't even in.
It wasn't even in.
Yeah.
That was almost two and a half years ago.
It wasn't even in.
And you guys are still not letting it go, bro.
I wasn't even part of the collab.
We never... I've never said anything after that stream and it's still going on.
It's still going on.
I was literally sleeping.
It's insane.
This is the lore.
Welcome to the lore.
Are we going in?
Okay, let's go.
Whoa, I'm in.
Oh, there's a lot of stuff here.
Oh yeah, there is.
I've been playing... Okay, I've only played this game on launch, so like, I don't know any of the new stuff.
I've never seen any of the new stuff.
Guys, I forgot guys.
New stuff?
Yeah, there's new stuff.
Oh, you've already played it recently, so you know what the new things are.
I don't.
Oh, hey.
Oh.
I don't know what you ate.
Yes, you do.
We're gonna get haunted.
Wait, we're gonna get haunted?
Why?
Oh, you took the battery.
Why did you take the battery?
Oh, shit.
I'm leaving.
Don't worry.
Leave.
Leave the loot here.
Okay, I'll bring this over.
I'm gonna bring it over.
What a fucking pussy.
Me.
I don't even know what the volume is getting.
Guys, is the volume good?
My sound guy's not here.
He's not here.
He's sleeping.
One of my mods, Silent Calcium, I see you in my chat.
Wait, where's the ladder?
How do we... Oh my God.
Why is it so bright?
Why is it so... Is it really bright for you?
Why is this so bright?
How... Where's the...
Oh my God.
Okay.
How do I get over here?
Oh, I got it.
Oh my god, it's so bright.
It's so bright.
Where's our ship?
I don't know where it is.
Wait, oh I see it.
You know the accident is not your fault.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, RPR drove the truck.
We are gonna do later company at 10 a.m.
And RPR said, no I can't.
Yeah, yeah, you know what?
We wanted to do the time that's not 1 a.m.
PST.
Guys, RPR vetoed it.
The only one.
Uto, Ditto and I, we were like, yeah, that's a good time.
Like it would have been 5 p.m.
PST.
We're like, yeah, that's a good, right?
Right, Ditto?
We're like, yeah, that's a good time.
And then RPR was like, no, that's...
That's too early.
That's his fault.
Yeah, that's his fault.
So we have to reschedule it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we had to reschedule it.
And now look what happened.
Uto's not here.
Wait, where did Ditto...
No, no, no, I saw something inside.
What do you mean?
There's an alien.
What?
Okay, we go in together.
It can't... we'll go in together.
Okay, okay, one...
One, two...
One, two, three.
Weren't you inside?
What are you doing?
I didn't trust you.
Because I know you were gonna...
You were gonna fuck with me.
Okay, okay, for real, for real.
Okay, okay, one...
Okay, ready?
One, two, three.
Weren't you inside?
Okay, okay, okay, three, two...
Okay, okay, okay.
One, two, three.
Okay.
No, no, no, no!
There's... okay.
Is she dead?
I don't know.
You're fine, you're fine!
What happened?
Wait, what's going on?
It's gone, it's gone.
I see it.
Okay.
He's camping, he's camping.
The main door.
Gorgz stop making money.
What?
Why are you talking?
He said we have to make money.
Hello?
RPR?
Oh, it's this guy!
He's friendly!
That's a friendly guy.
Okay, I'm not scared anymore.
I'm playing with...
I got you, I'm helping, I'm helping!
I'm helping!
Yeah, yeah, you bring that energy.
We're helping!
We're so helpful!
Oh my god!
Okay, we made a lot of money!
Yeah, we made so much money!
Yeah!
Yippee!
We're so helpful.
We went to get the other one.
Okay.
All right.
Don't have that much.
Okay!
All right, don't worry RPR.
RPR I'll come in with you this time.
Yeah, sure you are.
RPR don't worry!
No!
I did it!
We're gonna head over with you!
Don't worry.
Where are you?
Okay wait for us, wait for us!
We'll wait for Ditto, then we'll head there together.
I can't believe they're making Doki do all the work.
I know!
Dude, what do you mean?
Doki!
What do you mean I carried the stuff?
Is that not enough?
That I took out from the dangerous place.
That is not enough.
Oh yeah, you could have done any of that without Ditto and I.
It's enough.
It's dumb and dumber behind me.
We have G-Hundred.
Yeah, but he's greedy.
He likes money.
He's a greedy...
I can't wait to sacrifice you guys for the greater good.
See?
Look at him.
He doesn't care about the company.
He only cares about the money.
That's... Wait, R.P.O.
where are you?
Oh, he's so fast.
Where is he?
R.P.O., what are you doing?
That's not scary.
That's R.P.O.
We know that's you.
We know that's you, R.P.O.
That's you.
That's not even a good impression.
That's not even good.
That's you.
Yeah, we're not scared of you.
What are you doing?
So why are you following me if you're not scared?
Because we're a company.
Yeah, yeah.
Go make money then.
Then we'll make money with you.
It's dark.
We don't have time.
We have to go.
We have to go back.
Company together strong.
It's 8 PM.
It's enough.
What's going on?
What is that sound?
What is it?
It's us walking.
What are you talking about?
I hear something.
Yeah, I hear something.
Don't you hear it?
Oh, it's so dark.
I hear like a laughing sound.
Wait, is this a dead end?
What is that sound?
Why is it so dark?
Should I put my brightness up?
Why are you closing doors right here?
Why do you have to close the door?
Yeah, that's not a team thing.
We're a team.
There's a jump here.
Yeah, there's a jump.
What?
How?
What are you trying to do?
Huh?
It's too dark.
He's gonna fall.
Wait, he's gonna leave us.
We have to...
It's locked.
What's that sound?
Okay.
Make the jump.
Yeah, go.
Wait, what happened?
What did she do?
What happened?
She fell.
Wait, I'm scared.
How do I make the jump?
I'm scared.
So go back a little bit.
Go back a little bit and jump from a higher part.
Come on.
How do I make the jump?
Wait.
Oh, I got it.
There's a skinwalker with your voice.
Wait, what?
There is?
I don't hear it.
I just heard it.
Oh, shit.
I don't like that.
That's not cool.
I just heard you twice.
It was really scary.
We're okay.
Oh, shit.
It's 9.51.
Wait, what time do we have to go?
Midnight, I think.
Oh, we're fine.
We're fine.
We have plenty of time.
You know, it's okay.
See?
Look, we survived.
I told you.
Company together is strong.
I heard you talking to me and then I heard you in the distance talking.
And I was like, huh?
Wait, was I saying the same thing?
No, a different thing.
Oh, that's spooky.
That's freaky.
Or some laughing or some shit.
That was really spooky because you were laughing.
That's freaky.
Yeah!
Yeah, we did it!
We did it!
Yeah, now that's your fault.
I can't believe that Ditto died.
How is that my fault?
She failed the jump!
That's so fucked up!
You let her... You didn't teach her!
She failed the jump!
You didn't teach her!
How do I teach her to jump?
You could have taught her to jump better!
She didn't ask!
That is not her fault!
Yeah, you failed the jump, but you failed it 15 times without asking.
Yeah, but I didn't die.
Yeah, because I helped you.
Yeah, then why didn't you help her?
Why didn't you help her?
Because she didn't ask!
She just jumped and died instantly!
There was no time for me to help her!
How much more do you lose?
What are you talking?
You took the light off.
Yeah, look at that!
Minus 20%!
You took the light off.
I took the light off.
You took the light off?
Yeah, if you didn't take the light, everything would have been fine.
I took the lights off.
I'm landing the ship.
We're going.
I can't handle this.
She died and you laughed.
I took the lights off.
There was no reason to begin with!
I did laugh because it was funny because she was saying, oh, and then she died.
All you heard from Dita was, oh, and then she died.
And then she died.
I don't know if she was saying anything.
Oh, my God.
Someone in my chat said, Dito shouldn't have had to ask.
You should have been a good person and taught it.
Okay.
Okay, Doki.
But in my defense, Dito has been saying for the past.
I don't know how many days, but she's better than me at lethal company.
So, why do I need to teach someone that's better than me at the game how to jump over a fence?
You sort of write though, Dito.
I know.
I know how to jump.
I know how to jump, but I couldn't see anything.
So, it's your fault.
You didn't see.
Yeah, I couldn't see.
Whoa, where do we go?
There's a key.
Oh, there's a key.
You can see now.
Now we won't die because we can see.
I have a key.
I have a key too.
Oh, why is it so dark?
What?
It's more smoke.
Oh my god.
This is scary.
I'm scared.
This is sign of vision.
Okay, I got this.
No!
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
It's near us.
What is that?
No!
Oh my god.
What is this?
How can I see this?
Oh my god.
Here is like a lift sign.
Oh, okay.
If we stay here, he won't hurt us.
If we stay here.
Oh, wait.
Did you hear something?
Your voice.
There's a monitor too.
Oh, I don't hear it.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
We're here together.
It's okay.
I don't know how to fight with this one.
I don't know how to...
We have to go back.
Where is back?
I don't know where back is.
Let me this way.
I don't know where it is.
Are you sure?
Oh my god.
It's behind us.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is dead end.
I see it.
Okay, okay.
Where do we go?
Oh, okay.
I'm getting here.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
I'm leaving.
What the fuck was that?
Oh my god.
I'm going.
I'm leaving.
Where's the ship?
I don't know where the ship is.
Okay, we're gonna... We're okay.
We're alive.
Where's the ship?
I don't know where it is.
This ship went from zero to a hundred so fast.
Look.
It's survival of the fittest.
I have loot.
Where's the ship?
I'm so confused.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
I found it.
I found it, guys.
This is important.
We need... We need...
We need loot.
Okay.
Look.
We need the loot because... because...
Ditto keeps dying so we need the money.
Hey.
Is... What happened to Ditto?
Is Ditto dead?
I was gonna help her because there was a thing on her head.
Yeah.
But then Bracken came and I was like, Yeah, we're good.
Is she dead?
Yeah, she's dead.
I mean, why did you let her die again?
She's bad.
What do you want from me?
We're leaving.
Whoa!
That's fucked up.
She's not bad.
You're just a bad teacher.
I was not even teaching her anything.
How is it my fault?
You're a bad teacher.
She's better than me apparently.
She's supposed to be teaching me.
She's better than me.
Oh, no.
This is the second time that you...
This is the second time you didn't teach her.
Okay, bro.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, dude.
You killed me.
Yeah, you killed her.
How did I kill you?
I didn't kill you.
I can't believe you blamed the student.
I was gonna help you.
I was gonna help you get the thing off your head by fucking through the door, but then Bracken showed up and then that was it.
That was it.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you would do that to her.
You were supposed to be our supervisor.
You're like our supervisor.
You're not supervising good enough.
You should see the DMs between me and her.
She says she's better than me.
Is that true, Zito?
She's a part-timer.
Is that true?
What's my title?
Your title is leader.
That means you're better.
Your title is actually leader.
You have leaders.
You're literally the supervisor.
You're the leader.
Don't leave us.
You said you're better than me.
I am better than you.
So you should show me where to go.
She's a part-timer.
You're literally the leader.
I'm better than you just in text.
You're just better than me in text, but not in the actual.
So you're not better than me.
Are you better than RPR, Ditto?
Are you better than RPR?
I'm better than RPR.
Okay, then you're going first.
I follow RPR.
No, no, no.
You're going first.
Wait, but if you're better, then you should be the leader.
You should be the leader, Ditto.
You're better.
I know my place.
I'm bad.
She's so dead.
Where do we go, Ditto?
Come here.
Where?
Go first.
Where is here?
Here.
Okay, we're behind you.
We're following you.
Oh my god.
There's a turret.
You just gotta walk next to a turret.
Yeah, but we're okay.
Which one?
It's a turret.
Wait, what is a turret?
What is a turret?
No, that doesn't.
The next turret is the third.
Wait, no.
We just have to run past it.
You can do it.
See?
Look, you did it, RPRO.
What is this?
The back room?
What is this shit?
See?
She didn't...
She wasn't scared.
You almost died three times, Ditto.
It's okay.
I don't know.
She seems to...
She didn't die, though.
She's standing next to the turret.
And she's like, what?
I can see it.
That's true.
That's true, though.
Oh, I'm scared.
It's...
It's so dark here.
It's so dark.
Wait, I thought Ditto was like...
Oh, shit.
What is that?
I've never seen that before.
Look, look, look, look, look, look, look.
What is that?
That's a thing.
What is the thing?
Don't look away, you fucking...
I'm gonna rescue you.
I'll be okay.
Okay, okay.
If you look away, fall.
A little pause.
It's like the annual.
So, if I do this?
So...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Help me.
No.
I got a flashlight.
Pick up the load.
No!
Keep looking!
Go!
I'm watching!
Go, Eric!
Now it's over!
It's over!
Wait,
she fell off the map, didn't she?
Oh my god!
That's so creepy!
I didn't realize that's a hole!
Oh my god!
I didn't realize that was a hole!
I'm scared!
I'm so scared!
Oh no!
He's so dead!
Okay!
Can he open doors?
Door?
Oh, is he dead?
Yeah, can he open doors?
Wait, wait, wait!
Wait!
I hear your voice too!
Wait, you hear my voice?
I don't hear any of the skinwalkers!
I'm so dead right now.
Did I install it wrong?
Okay, he's dead end.
Oh, he's dead end.
He's so fucked.
He's dead end.
How can, how can we...
Oh, he's right there!
Wait, he can open doors!
He can open doors!
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
Oh!
It would be so funny if there was a monster behind him.
That would be so funny.
Oh, what the heck!
He can open the door too!
What?
It's scary!
Oh?
I need the fucking side door chat!
Wait, we can't...
He can't die though!
Because we have so much loot!
If he dies, we lose everything!
Oh, PR!
What's that sound?
Is, is he dead end?
No?
No, no, he's trying to find a side door.
He's thinking he's not following me without making any audio.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I saw it!
I saw it!
Saw what?
I saw the, I saw the, the, the, the, the, the, the guy!
I don't think he saw it!
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh!
He went, he went the other side.
Get the fuck out of me, bitch!
What the fuck?
Oh shit!
Oh my god, he didn't see it!
I saw it!
How am I gonna get out?
Oh, that's so scary!
Oh my god!
That's so scary!
Oh, that's so scary!
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead!
He's so dead!
What is he doing?
What is this spider bomb?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Okay, I'm gonna hot shit this, like it's Joe work.
Oh my god!
What is he gonna do?
Joe, what are you doing?
What the fuck is this?
Is it over?
I think so, I don't think he's gonna live.
What if I...
I don't think he's gonna live.
There's no way.
Fuck it.
Ah!
Yes!
I live!
I have no weapon!
Bro!
I feel like a guy!
The core is fine, but the big fucker with the white shoulders came, man.
Oh, how could you do this?
Why didn't you tell me there was a hole there?
How did you guys...
I jumped into the hole.
Oh, wait, we lost.
We lost everything.
Yeah, we lost everything.
We jumped into the hole and it's a fucking bomb!
I didn't know!
I thought there was a platform!
You didn't tell me!
I didn't tell you!
You're the leader!
Oh my God!
Ay caramba!
We're so dead.
There's no way!
It's zero days!
We don't have anything!
Goodbye!
Oh!
What's life?
How does anyone...
We all die!
There's no reason!
We have no money!
The company can't kill us if we kill ourselves first.
Our life was in our own hands.
We had like 400.
Yeah, you guys definitely had 400.
You guys did great.
You guys did amazing, guys.
I can't believe we're getting a game over already.
I thought I was playing with pros.
What happened?
I'm doing my part.
I thought I was playing with pro players.
I'm the baby.
I told you guys I was the baby.
You know what?
If Uto was here...
If Udo was here, this wouldn't have happened.
It would go exactly the same.
If Udo was here, she would have helped carry us.
She's a good player.
She's very good at this game.
Yeah, she would be a team player.
So really, it's Ditto's fault we're losing because she didn't tell Udo the time.
Wow.
Yeah, honestly, I agree.
Because I know it's not my fault.
I showed up.
I was a guest.
I did my part.
That was my only job.
Put it on my schedule and then show up.
I didn't look at the hazard level and now it's foggy.
I can't see anything.
Oh my god.
I can't see.
So many ads.
What is Tyler Wong doing?
I can't see.
I'm here.
Oh my gosh, where is the door?
Oh, there's the door.
Okay.
Okay, only one.
Where did he go?
There's a turret.
That's the only way we can go though.
No, we're going there.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
Mine on the left.
There's a mine.
What's that?
Oh, is that a key?
Yeah.
I heard another mine.
There's another mine.
Where is it?
I hear it.
Don't you hear the...
Yeah, but I don't see it.
Wait, I hear my voice.
Oh, so we all want to go in.
Okay.
I heard my own voice somewhere.
Yeah, but you were talking.
Yeah.
I don't know if that was a skinwalker or something.
Or like...
Or like somebody's mic.
I didn't hear the skinwalker.
Oh, maybe it's the echo.
Okay.
Wait, isn't this the bracket room?
Wait, there's a key.
You need to take it.
Yeah, this is the back room.
Like, east or right, I guess.
Okay.
What's that?
There is a tattered metal sheet.
I'll take that.
It's like stuck.
Yeah.
How do I grab it?
I took it.
Oh, okay.
Jumping time.
Ow!
I made it.
There's two engines here, but I'm a fool.
I can do this.
Wait.
I can do it.
Can you carry this key?
Yeah, I can carry it.
Okay, there's two engines here, and those are expens- Uh-huh.
Where do we do this?
We have to find the side door.
We can't jump backwards.
Wait, why can't we jump backwards?
Why?
Why can't?
Because we're carrying an engine.
Oh!
Wait, why can't you jump forward?
I mean, we could jump backwards.
Wait, why can't I see shit in here?
Yeah, why is this here?
Oh, the exit is here.
The exit is here.
Wait, where?
Right here, below.
Oh, I can't see jack shit.
Oh, I see it!
Yeah!
Okay, I'll bring it up.
Alright.
Yeah, I'm doing my part.
I'm doing my part.
Okay.
Me too.
I'm doing my part.
Yeah.
Okay, let's go.
We're so helpful.
I don't- No, I can't see.
Where are you?
Left side, left side.
Left side?
Okay.
Yeah.
I can't jump.
I can't.
My hands are so full.
Wait, where are you, Ditto?
I can't see!
I'm blind!
Under you!
You're under?
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna follow you.
You're like my dog.
You know, like blind people with dogs?
What is the main- What is mantecoy?
It's a bird.
Oh, okay, that's just a bird.
Okay, thank god.
Okay, I was gonna say.
I thought that was an enemy.
It's your friend.
Yeah, it's my friend.
Wait, did I put it in?
Okay.
Why is it so fox- Foxy?
Cause like, RPR didn't check the land, and it's- AHHHHH!
What was that?
Was that RPR?
RPR, was that you, you bitch?
You fucking bitch!
You fucking let me in!
You fucking!
Let me in!
We're leaving, right?
Get us in!
Then I swear to god, I will yell, and then I swear to god, I swear to god, dogs will come over.
And then there will be no power, and it will be your fault.
Dogs will come over, and I hope the fucking ship dies.
Yes, yes, yes.
Open the door!
Oh, we're in!
Yay!
Look at that, the laziest employee!
That's you!
You got the laziest employee!
And the most profitable employee.
Most paranoid, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, not according to the company, you're the laziest.
Yeah, because you guys stole my loot!
We got the loot together.
No!
Not!
We were there with you when we got the loot!
Stop slacking off!
I brought us the most, I bring us the most money every time.
That's not true.
Because the last game, we didn't make any money.
We didn't make any money last game.
Yeah, but I had the most money on my dead body.
Yeah, but you were dead.
That doesn't count.
You know what?
We don't need you!
You are this too!
Ditto and I can do it without you.
Right, Ditto?
Yeah!
Okay, we'll go.
You go in first.
Let's go, let's go.
Why me first?
Okay, because we're a team.
Okay, okay, listen to me.
Regular...
Why me?
Why was it me?
I'm so fucked up!
I don't fucking want to be now!
What the fuck?
Oh, my God!
Is Ditto dead?
Is she dead?
I feel like she's dead!
Is she not making it?
Oh, fuck!
It's the back room!
I'm not going to check!
Because I'm waiting to be!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, my God!
There's nothing here!
Where's...
She's dead!
She's actually dead!
Where's the ship?
I don't remember where the ship is.
Oh, my God!
Okay, I need to take her back to the ship!
I don't know where it is!
Oh, fuck!
I can't believe she's dead!
Wait, you didn't even leave the ship?
That's so fucked up!
You didn't even leave the ship!
What are you doing?
Wait, you don't need me!
I'm dead!
I brought the load!
And there's no loot in your hands!
But you don't need me, right?
I brought the load!
I brought her!
You guys don't need me, but she died within three seconds of being out!
And you throw that...
She died!
No, no, no!
She caused her own death!
That was not...
She tried to pick up the fucking...
I'm going in!
I'm 1 HP!
Would it be fucked up if I start the ship while...
Would it be fucked up if I start the ship while he's up there?
Look, I...
I did my job!
Oh, I don't know about you.
A boat has been cast.
Okay, I didn't do that though.
Okay, that's not my fault.
RPR!
RPR, the boat has been casted!
It's okay.
That's not my fault.
Ditto was the one that voted.
I'm not leaving the ship now that I know.
Okay, the moment... Okay, guys.
The moment...
I don't know if he's gonna come back!
I need to see if he comes back!
If he comes...
And the moment I see his shadow... like a shadow of him or hear his voice, I'll make sure the ship flies away so he can see the ship flying away before he can get on.
Wait, check the monitor?
That's me.
No, he's still alive.
See?
Oh, I can leave while he's still out there.
Oh my god, look at him.
Look, there he is.
Whose body is that?
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Oh, man.
What happened?
Why didn't you just leave me behind, you dumbass?
I didn't do anything!
I did not...
I was bringing loot back!
I'm too useless fucking dumbass!
I didn't do anything!
She voted!
What did you do that?
You're a dumbass!
I didn't know!
You die, you waste our money, and then you fuck us!
I was just on the ship!
I didn't do anything!
I didn't know!
What is that command?
Don't click that shit.
It makes the ship leave.
Oh, it's I.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, alright.
Not only did she die, she costed us money, and then she took the ship away!
So I died too!
I was just chilling in the ship.
I don't know what was going on.
Why were you hiding the ship?
Because I was 1 HP!
Because Zed-O fucking set up the whore next to us!
I was whoring!
So we can do this.
Together, Zed-O.
We don't need RPR.
We go this way.
Okay.
No, no, no.
We go this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're a team.
Let's go.
We don't need RPR.
Oh, that's a joke.
Yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
RPR, RPR.
We swap.
RPR.
RPR, we're swapping.
RPR, we can go.
RPR.
Where is he?
We swap.
You go the other way.
There's a turret.
You're better at that.
What's that sound?
Do you hear that?
What's that?
Oh, he took the battery!
Why did you take the battery?
Oh my god.
You're chewing the can.
Why did you take the battery?
We can't see.
Yeah.
Yeah, how are you gonna split up?
I lied.
Don't worry.
We'll bring this back.
We're gonna do our job.
Okay, okay.
I will bring it back to you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't jump.
If we jump, this thing breaks down.
Oh, I see.
Alright, nice.
Okay, where's... Oh, there's the ship.
Wait, where's the ship?
Do you remember where the ship is?
Um...
You wanna go?
Here, here, here.
Oh, okay, okay.
I'm gonna follow you.
I don't remember.
You can... you can click... like...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see it now.
Look at us go.
We're such good... we're such good workers.
See?
We got loot.
Yeah.
We got loot for the company.
Yeah, we're making money.
Alright.
Okay, I have to go.
I went the wrong way.
I went the wrong... it's this way.
It's this way.
Nice.
Look at us.
Money.
We're team players.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We don't need him.
Where's the main entrance?
I have no idea.
Wait, where's the... where is the...
Maybe just... here, here, here.
Over there.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can go down... let's do the side entrance.
Because he's at main entrance.
We'll do the side entrance.
I see.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll do the side entrance here.
Okay.
We can do this.
I believe in us.
We don't need RPR.
We don't need him.
Yeah, we can do each game.
Yeah, yeah.
We're better than him.
Or two of us.
Two is better than one.
Yeah, yeah, see?
Look!
We have a sign!
Yeah!
Already!
Okay, okay, okay.
Two game.
Oh, we have two weapons!
Look at that!
Okay, okay.
We should kill... we should kill RPR with this.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Before... before... before we take off the shield.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
No, no.
Let's go to main entrance.
We go to the main entrance and we wait for him.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We wait for him.
Can... can... where can we... um... go on top?
Woo!
Yeah, yeah.
We go... he's here.
He's here.
This way.
We go up to the main entrance and we wait for him.
And then we steal his loot after.
That's nice.
Yeah, he won't know.
He won't know.
He'll...
Look
at all this loot!
Okay, okay.
We will stand... you stand on the other side and then I'll stay.
Okay.
Nice!
Nice plan!
This is such a good plan!
So good!
Yes!
Yeah!
We can just wait here.
We can't be like you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're gonna... we're gonna wait for him and then when he comes up we'll be like...
Yeah, cause... cause fire.
Cause fire.
Yeah, we're gonna... we're gonna steal his money.
We're gonna steal it.
He won't be ready for this.
I think he... he will get back in maybe one hour, one or two hours.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He has to.
He's gonna... he has to cause he has so much loot on him.
Yup.
We... we can... we will be able to do this.
We'll be fine.
Okay.
Oh, wait, wait.
What... what if he... he's dead?
What if he's dead?
If he's dead...
Oh, if he's dead he would start the ship.
He would start the ship if he's dead.
Oh, right.
Yeah, yeah.
There's no way.
Oh, you're right.
He would start the ship.
He would be like, look at these dumbasses.
And then he's gonna start the ship.
Like...
Oh, no.
That makes sense.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't... I think he's still alive.
He has to be still alive.
There's no way.
He's gonna come through this entrance here.
We wouldn't hear him.
If he... if he went through the side entrance we would hear him on the side.
Okay.
Yeah, don't worry.
We're ready.
We're ready for him.
Look.
He... he was cocky for too long.
We were tired of his leadership.
He's a bad leader, right, Ditto?
Yes.
He's a bad leader.
So we have to get rid of him.
Oh my god.
If Uto was here...
If...
Wait!
He's dead!
He died!
Oh shit, go away!
You didn't hear that, right?
Did he hear... do you think he heard that?
Do you think he heard that?
No, right?
He didn't hear all of that, right, guys?
He didn't.
No, right guys?
He didn't hear that.
It's okay.
We're coming back to the ship.
Wait, where did Ditto go?
Wait, where the fuck did Ditto go?
Ditto, where are you?
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
I can't align.
Okay, here, don't worry, we're fine.
Look at that, we lived!
We lived.
Wait, what the fuck was that?
Ditto?
What is that?
What is that sound?
Wait, wait, wait.
I hear something, I hear.
What is that sound?
I hear something!
Let's go, let's go!
Oh my god.
Look, we lived!
We have loot and we lived!
The most laziest employee!
Yay!
Wow!
So lazy!
The most laziest employee!
I know, he's so lazy.
What happened?
Why were you so lazy?
Why did you die?
API?
API, why don't you talk to us?
API, why won't you talk to us?
Are you mad at us?
API, why don't you talk to us?
API, you don't talk to us, I'm gonna throw our loot off the ship.
I'm crazy enough to do it, you don't believe me?
I'm gonna fucking throw this sign off.
I'm gonna throw this off the clip right now.
I'm gonna throw this off if you don't talk to us.
API, why don't you talk to us?
API, don't do this.
Don't do this, API.
Why don't you talk to us?
Talk to us.
I'm flying!
I'm going to
test that.
Test that, I think.
Test that.
Goodbye.
What?
What the fuck?
Goodbye.
Yay!
We made money!
We got money!
Wait, oh wait!
Guys, I don't think we made the money, guys.
Yay, we reached the quota!
I just want you to know, Doki, that when you least expect it, in the darkness of the caves, I'm coming for you.
What do you mean?
What did I do?
How did we kill you?
I'm coming for you.
We didn't even kill you!
We were like, alive!
When you least expect it, in the deepest, darkest parts of the dungeons, I'm coming for you.
What did we do?
We were like, waiting for you.
Oh, no!
Waiting for me to kill me as I'm carrying 300 plus crap on me, yeah!
You think I didn't see that?
You think I didn't see all of that?
And then you leave us!
You leave me and Vito with all the loot outside the ship!
So we just lost 500!
But we made a hundred!
We made the quota!
Go back to part of me!
I'll play along!
Oh my god, he's angry!
Why is he so angry?
What do we do?
Bro, what is wrong with him?
Why is he so angry?
If Uto was here, he would kill.
No, no.
But we didn't even do anything!
It was just talking!
Yeah!
We're just talking!
We're just having a conversation!
We haven't done anything!
Yeah, we can't talk now!
Yeah, what's wrong?
We can't even talk now?
It's a bird!
Oh, there's a jump!
You first!
Okay!
I believe in you!
Yes!
Whoa!
Okay, my turn!
Woo!
You did it!
Okay!
There's a door over here!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Yay!
It's not a main entrance!
Let's go!
We don't need him!
Wait, wait!
There's a loot!
Loot!
I got loot!
Okay, I already got loot!
I already got his loot!
Okay, nice!
What is this?
What is that?
Oh, is it a switch?
It's a switch!
I don't like that!
Oh, we can...
What did you do?
I don't know!
I don't like that.
What did you do?
Okay, the light's on.
Oh, okay, I turned everything on.
Okay.
Here we go.
Wait, what's that sound?
Are you cursed?
Wait, he's cursed!
What's that?
That's a cursed item!
He's gonna kill us.
I think he's gonna try to kill us.
That's a cursed item!
What was that item?
So like when you hold onto it, a ghost monster is gonna chase you.
Ahhhh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is that cursed?
Is that...
Maybe.
Oh, it's just a toy?
Oh, never mind.
I lied.
It's just a toy.
But here, this item!
Oh look, we found this.
This.
Yeah.
Nice.
Go back.
Yeah, let's go back where we came from.
Because like, our player is gonna do the main room, right?
Yes.
So we can do this up.
So we can do like the side room.
We haven't gotten this way yet.
Is this the back room?
Oh, never mind.
Oh, that's just the back room.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, there's nothing there.
We could go... we could go left.
We could go here.
Yeah, go left.
Oh, there's nothing.
This is so smart!
But he was here, so we could go this way.
Okay.
Because he was on the other side.
It's so dark.
I know.
Oh, it's a turret.
Turret.
Okay, we can go this way.
There's not a turret here too.
Oh, there he is.
Hey.
Hey, RPR.
He ran away.
He's not talking!
Why is he not talking?
Yeah, why you don't talk to us?
Why you don't talk to us?
Yeah, we're good people.
I don't understand.
We've been so nice to him.
I think he was here.
He went all the way here because all the doors are open.
Okay.
I don't know where we are now.
Wait, there's a...
Oh, hey!
Look out!
There's a sloop!
Wait, why does he hate us all?
He hates me!
What are you doing?
I'm still in the sloop!
Here, come here!
He's angry!
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop!
Woo!
Okay.
I'm 1 HP.
Okay, okay.
I'm alive.
But where do we go?
I don't know where to go.
Oh, um...
We should follow you.
Maybe this way?
I'm lost.
I'm already lost.
Maybe this way?
To the ship.
I can't believe it.
I stole his stuff.
Let's go to the ship.
Where's Afio?
Is he dead?
No, I think he's alive.
If he was dead, he would start the ship.
Shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh.
Wait,
I hear...
I hear you voice, too!
Skinwalker!
Oh my god.
We did it!
Yay!
Afio is the laziest again!
You literally got me killed.
How did we...
What did we do?
You made the little dumbass mad.
Which dumbass?
Which what?
The guy that wants to loot.
Yeah, but like, why did he chase you?
Just give him a piece of loot!
Because you guys brought him to me!
It's unbelievable.
I believe in karma.
Karma is coming for you.
Did you get killed by the bug?
Yeah, he got...
Look at him, he got killed by a bug.
Look at him, he got...
I can't believe it.
He got killed by a tiny bug.
Karma is coming.
I didn't die.
What do you mean?
He got killed by a bug.
Look at him.
It's our fault, right?
What did we do?
I feel like he is getting karma.
Not us.
Not us, not us.
We have been good.
I only died one time.
He is trying to...
He is going to revenge us.
Yeah.
No...
He can't.
If he revenges...
He loses everything.
Woah, a bottle!
Wait, I got something.
Oh, you got something?
Oh, nice.
Yep.
Oh yeah, we're already doing our job.
Karma doesn't exist for us, because we're good people.
Right?
Right, Zitto?
Yes, yes.
It's so dark!
Yeah, there's nothing in here.
Oh, I think someone has nothing in there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's too dark.
There's nothing in here, too.
I think we have to go to this side.
It's Day-In!
Yeah, it's all Day-In.
All Day-In.
Hello?
Wait, Day-In's here.
So we have to go up.
It's Day-In, too!
Oh, yeah, yeah, there's something here!
Oh, yeah, yeah, Gavin.
Oh, nice!
It's moving.
Look at us!
We're so efficient!
We're so good at this.
Wait, it's all Day-In.
Day-In!
Oh, wait.
Oh, where do we go?
We should go here.
Is that the Day-In?
Yeah, that's the Day-In.
It's also Day-In.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
This is all Day-In.
Oh, I guess we go.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, we just bring this back.
Take it back to the ship first.
Yeah.
Yay!
RPR has been the laziest employee the most.
Yeah.
We're doing our job.
Keep him busy.
We're not gonna make any profit.
I know.
He's not gonna make any money for the company.
Oh, he got the battery.
Okay.
He took the battery again.
Okay, but wouldn't it be funny if we just start the ship?
I think he's gonna quit the game.
Okay, but if you do it, he won't.
Are you sure?
Are you sure about that?
Yeah.
Okay.
He told that.
He told...
Yeah.
No, no, no.
The last time you saved...
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think you should do it.
I think...
Is it okay?
If you do it, he won't be mad.
Okay.
I think if you do it, he won't be mad.
Yeah, yeah.
We have one quarter.
So, this time, it's my turn.
You guys are insane.
In the fucking head.
Oh,
it's just...
I think we're gonna have to...
I didn't do it!
It was ditto!
I wasn't even the one that did it.
Let's go here.
I can't believe he was the laziest employee again though.
Are we gonna make quota?
No, no, no.
We have...
If you go get the loot, we will.
Our last time.
Yeah, we got this.
We can do this.
Yeah, we can do it.
Go fucking make money.
We are making money.
Look at all the stuff we brought in.
I think it's because we keep splitting up.
If we...
Hello?
Go make money.
I'm done.
I'll make enough money.
We made money.
We made money too.
Go make money.
Wait, why did you take us to the hardest world?
Why did you take us to the...
Go make money.
I'm done making... I made enough money.
You guys can make money.
It's too hard for us.
It's the last day.
If you guys don't make money, you will lose.
So go make money.
I'm not doing anything.
It's the hard world.
We need help.
I'm gonna watch you guys through the cameras here.
Yeah, but we don't have a walkie-talkie.
Here, I'll buy you walkie-talkies.
But that's a waste of our money.
We're gonna waste money.
Here, go pick up walkie-talkies, guys.
Are you mad at us?
I'm on a strike.
I don't care.
Are you mad at us?
What do we do, RPR?
Let's mediate.
Go make money or we die.
But where's the walkie-talkie?
I don't mind dying.
I don't mind dying because I've already been multiple times.
What is... I have no puppy on this mind.
Wait, where's the walkie-talkie?
There it is.
Can I get memory this way?
But you need the walkie-talkie too, RPR.
I don't need shit.
I'll stop right now.
They're so fucking dead.
You're so fucking dead.
Shit.
Where's the end?
Wow.
AHHHHH!
That I'm here.
That I'm gonna make money.
I'm gonna make money.
You think he's mad at us?
Yeah, he's mad at us.
But what do we do?
What do we do?
We need like 50.
Yeah, why don't we just go to the side entrance.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know what we did.
We were just like, We're good employees.
What is this?
Is this hard?
How hard?
What's that?
There's a face hugger.
What is this?
It's a bag.
Yeah, he like grabs your face.
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh.
Is this 50?
Let me see.
Scan.
Oh, we need one more.
We need one more item.
We need one more.
Oh, I found the main entrance.
Okay, okay.
I found one more.
Oh, okay, okay.
We made it.
Ditto?
Oh, I think she's dead.
Oh, we made it.
I think she's dead.
Oh.
We have to get out of here.
That sounds awful.
I don't know how to get home.
What do we do?
They're all dead!
They're swinging!
I'm not dead!
We got money!
Wait, Ditto crashed.
Wait, the game crashed.
The game...
They crashed the game!
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Bro, it was lagging so hard!
I've seen Ditto like running in the...
in the stall, standing still.
We did it, RPR!
We did it!
All you got was two pieces of loot.
We made quota!
Yeah, we made quota!
Do I need to remind you that you murdered me?
Lazy as a pony!
You murdered me multiple times while I was carrying hundreds of thousands of scrap!
Okay, you dying is not murder.
Yeah!
You leaving me on the planet is not murder.
We didn't do anything.
You leaving me...
Let me put this into perspective.
Put this into perspective, okay?
You guys left me on the planet three times already while I was carrying loot.
And then one time I go inside and you guys actually find loot, which are stop signs.
I accidentally die with four pieces of loot, a lot of money on me, and I spectate you guys, planning to kill me as I walk through the door, carrying the loot to save you guys from the fucking company!
But it was just talk!
We didn't do it!
Yeah, we didn't do it!
We were just talking!
Do you think that we are gonna do that to you?
Yeah, we were just talking!
There's no way we're gonna do that to you!
It was just a fantasy!
We were just talking!
There's no way we can do that!
Yeah, why would we do that to you?
You had so much money!
Yeah, it's unbelievable.
We need 70 more!
I got a key!
No, don't sell keys!
Don't sell keys!
Why not?
But we need more money!
We have enough money!
Okay, okay!
Look, we did it!
It's over!
We lost!
Wait, what?
I thought you said we had enough!
Vito, you're carrying!
You're carrying!
Here, here, here!
I will sell everything!
I will sell the key!
Is that 40?
That's 10 dollars!
That's 24!
We lost!
No, no, I have a key!
That key is 3!
We have a key!
We did it!
We will use the corner!
Yeah!
Wait, there's a coffee mug!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
See?
I told you!
The key works!
Yeah, we did it!
We did it!
See?
You're lucky!
We did it!
I found the coffee mug!
I found that coffee mug!
Nice, nice!
I'm selling it!
Oh, I saved the day!
Yippee!
You have a coffee mug!
Shut the fuck up!
It would have literally had 3000 scrap right now if you guys didn't kill me!
Look, we didn't do anything!
You killed yourself!
Yeah!
You're crazy!
You guys are crazy!
You guys are literally plotting against us!
No, no, no!
We are the same team!
If Uto was here, if Uto was here, Yeah!
you wouldn't be yelling at us!
Like this!
Yes, I would!
We're on the same fucking team!
Yeah, so why are you so mean to us?
Are you crazy in the head?
Like, hello?
Have you been here the past hour with me?
I'm playing solo!
We helped!
We got the coffee mug!
Right, Tito?
We got the coffee mug that got us the quota!
Yeah!
Make money!
More money, less talking!
We need walkie-talkies!
I want walkie-talkies!
I'm gonna buy stuff!
Alright, you wanna buy stuff?
I'm gonna buy stuff.
Help, store.
Well, I'm gonna buy something that won't be a waste of money!
I'm gonna buy stuff!
Oh my god!
What are you gonna buy?
I'm gonna buy this.
Walkie-talkie?
I did it.
I bought something.
Nice.
Don't worry, I bought something useful.
Let's wait for the...
Let's wait for the package.
Oh my god, he go by himself!
He go alone again.
Don't worry, don't worry.
If he die, he's gonna blame all of us.
Yeah, he's gonna blame us if he dies.
But it's not our fault.
We didn't do anything.
Yeah, we're shopping.
Look, look what I got!
What is this?
How much?
Did you buy things?
Yeah, yeah, don't worry.
Look.
Here, here.
I'm just gonna...
No, no, this is a good purchase!
It's a good purchase!
It's like motivation losing.
Look.
Nice one, nice one.
It's good money!
Okay, wait, wait.
I'll buy something else.
Let's see.
Store.
We can buy...
Let's buy walkie-talkie.
We'll buy two.
Walkie.
Oh my god, let's get a table!
Wait, we can buy a toilet!
Buy what?
Toilet!
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
I have never seen toilet!
Yeah, yeah, we can use this as bathroom things.
We can buy a toilet!
It's needed.
Nice, nice.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
We don't tell him.
Shh!
Wait, is it inside?
Oh my god, look!
It's a toilet!
Look!
Which one?
It's here!
Oh my god, toilet!
Oh my god!
Okay, let's buy walkie-talkie.
Okay, I'll buy walkie-talkie.
I'll buy walkie-talkie for real.
Okay.
Let's go.
Wait, we can move it.
Let's move this.
Okay, wait, wait.
Okay.
There.
Oh, nice, nice!
Let's get the walkie-talkie.
Okay.
I will walkie-talkie.
Let's go.
How do I use this?
Okay.
Hello?
Yeah, I can hear you.
Okay, I can hear you.
Alright, let's go, let's go.
Look.
Where's the entrance?
Let's go.
Let me go straight.
Okay, I'll follow you.
Here, here, here.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
See, we're being so...
Careful!
It's a flag.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can die from that.
Yeah, I have every...
I have every die from this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is expensive walkie-talkie.
How much?
It was like $20.
Where's the entrance?
Oh, there, there, there, there, there!
I see it, I see it, I see it.
Okay, let's go.
We have walkie-talkies now.
Oh, there's a lot of stuff!
There's a lot of stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, that's a lot of stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hello, do you hear me?
Okay, okay.
We're taking bags.
We're taking bags?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're taking bags.
Okay, okay.
Look at us.
Okay.
With this, we can make a lot of money.
Yeah, yeah, we can...
We did it.
We're doing our part.
Yes.
Yeah.
Look at us go.
We're so helpful!
We're making money!
Okay, I'm 1 HP.
Why?
I'm 1 HP.
Oh, me too.
Me too.
Okay, we shouldn't...
I think we can come from this.
This way, this way.
I don't think we should go inside.
We're 1 HP.
We did our part.
We...
I have to wait for this sign.
Alright.
Wait, where's the ship?
Do you know where the ship is?
I never know where the ship is.
Maybe on our left side?
Oh, okay.
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Yeah, I scanned it.
Which one?
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's this way.
I think?
Okay, no, I don't.
I don't see it.
I'm lost.
Oh.
Did you lie?
No, I didn't lie.
I'm just stupid.
Where's the ship?
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
You're just stupid!
No!
You can be stupid!
Only up here stupid is enough, okay?
Okay.
Maybe we can all be...
You can be more stupid.
Okay, I'm stupid, but not that stupid.
Okay.
Only up here...
is enough.
Yay!
We made money!
Wait, where's our boombox?
Wait, where does our music box go?
Oh, I have it!
Wait!
Okay, okay.
Is up here dead?
Is he?
Oh, no!
He's dead!
Wait, is he dead?
No, maybe he's hiding.
Is he hiding?
I think he's dead.
No, no, he has to be hiding.
He doesn't move.
Wait, how do I... where's my walkie-talkie?
Did I drop it?
Where's my walkie-talkie?
I'm gonna go back again.
Where's my walkie-talkie though?
Oh, we should give him a little...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe we should all go back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should go back and get the loot.
Oh, my... oh, where's my walkie-talkie?
This way, this way.
I think I dropped it when we fell.
Okay.
I think it's...
Is it this way?
You following?
I don't know how to get back.
This way, this way.
Okay, okay, okay.
I follow you.
I'm already lost.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This way?
I think you dropped it at the main entrance.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, I think so.
When I was picking stuff up, yeah.
Okay, we have...
Oh,
my gosh.
I hear... I hear... I hear Doki's voice.
I hear your voice!
There's my walkie-talkie!
Walkie-talkie!
Why is she talking to you?
Grab it, grab it, grab it.
I got this.
Okay, okay.
Go back.
Hey, hey, hey.
Wait!
It's dark now, so there's a lot of monsters outside.
Shh, shh, shh, shh.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
I have this.
What the f...
I don't know where to go.
Maybe this way.
Okay.
Oh, there's...
That's me, that's me.
Oh, I see it, I see it.
Oh.
Oh, shh.
Oh, shh, shh.
Oh, no!
Yeah!
No!
Dad, we're all dead!
We're all dead!
Are you dead?
You dead?
Karma has come out and bit you in the ass once again.
What the f...
I literally made so much money that run and you guys are f***ing around with walkie-talkies and that's why we...
What do you mean?
I made like over 400 in that run.
No, but we...
Just to watch you guys f*** with a toilet and f*** walkie-talkies.
But f*** this toilet.
No!
What happened to our toilet?
What is your toilet?
It's so hard.
What happened to our toilet?
F*** your toilet.
I believe in it.
You deleted the toilet!
Do we get our money back?
Do we get our toilet money back?
Oh my god.
No!
You guys don't get to have fun until we make money in this f***ing house!
But we...
We did make money!
But you made zero!
You all died!
We were!
Our toilet!
We worked so hard!
Did he delete it?
No, it's in storage.
I bought us walkie-talkies!
So we can use it.
Okay.
I couldn't buy us a boombox.
We were broke.
We didn't have enough.
We didn't have money.
It's in his storage.
He kept it.
Our walkie-talkie!
Nice, nice!
Oh, here!
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Yay!
Where's the other one?
Oh, there it is.
Yay!
Alright, let's do it.
Let's make money.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have walkie-talkies.
We're gonna make some money.
Yay!
How do we get up?
Ummm...
We have to go another way.
Why does he always split up with us?
Why doesn't he wanna work with us?
Oh, here, here, here, here, here.
I don't understand.
We're like a team, right?
Yeah, he always go alone, right?
Yeah, why does he always go alone?
If he stops going alone, then we wouldn't die.
There's no point to play with cheap people if he runs off.
Yeah, yeah.
If he's in a solo, no wonder he keeps dying.
If he had us with him, he wouldn't be dying.
We're trying to be a team player.
Let's find him.
Let's try to find him.
RPR!
What's that?
Oh, that's a slum.
That's a slum.
What is that?
What happened?
It's a slum.
Does it kill you?
Yeah, it kills you.
Yeah, walk into it.
Let's see what happens.
No, I think it kills you, right?
It's gonna kill us.
No, it's okay.
We...
Something is gonna kill you.
Something is gonna kill you anyway.
No, we have to work together.
We make a line.
RPR, we have to work together.
As a team.
We can work together.
We have...
I'm gonna die?
I think he's gonna die.
Isn't he?
Where did he go?
Oh, he's over there.
Okay.
Go get the loot while I'm dealing with this slum shit.
But we wanna work with you.
I can't move!
There's a slime in front of me!
Go get the loot!
Okay, we'll get the loot.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I got loot.
Look.
I saw you.
You got GG loss.
I got loot.
Look.
See?
I got loot.
Yeah, bring it out the door.
I did it!
Okay, I'll go this side.
Okay.
Oh, I got more...
The slime is mad at you.
This time you will die.
Oh!
There's a bug!
What do I do?
He's
dead!
He's dead!
Oh my god, he's dead!
I saw it!
Yes, he's dead!
He's dead!
I took...
Yes, he's dead!
Okay, okay, okay.
I didn't do anything!
I didn't!
I took this stuff.
He's dead!
Oh my god, oh my god!
Let's go!
Let's go back!
He's dead!
Where did we go?
What's this monster?
Oh, I don't know!
I don't know!
How do we get home?
He's dead again!
Wait, where's our ship?
I don't know where the ship is!
I always relied on you.
What happened?
What happened inside?
I don't know!
He just... There was just so many things happening!
I don't know what happened!
I'm dying!
This way, this way, this way!
Okay, okay, okay.
It's okay.
I took his load.
Oh my god.
Wait, where's home?
Where's home?
Oh, here, here.
I can't remember.
This way.
Okay, okay, okay.
I don't know what happened.
There were so many monsters!
Yeah!
There were so many monsters and then he died!
Why he die?
He did again.
I don't know!
I don't know how he died this time!
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
He died every time.
I know!
He's the laziest employee!
Okay.
Nice.
He's dead in two days.
Oh yeah, I think he's dead.
Look.
Yeah, he's dead.
Look, look.
See?
I saw he got eaten.
You saw him get eaten?
By what?
Yeah!
By the monster!
The monster!
Oh my god!
Okay, then we go, I guess.
I guess we have to go now.
Oh, how much?
How many?
How much money we have?
Not a lot.
We made $79.
But we have to go.
Okay.
Go next.
We go next.
Yeah, we go next.
This next.
We have walkie-talkies now!
We give one to RPR!
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, we give... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Give one to RPR.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Give one to him.
Oh my god, he's... he's employee.
How did you die?
Don't talk to me.
You literally brought the whole army of monsters to me.
What do you mean how I died?
I was so scared.
I was trying to get out.
Yeah, you got out.
That's the expense of my life.
But you could have got out too.
Up here, here, here.
Take my walkie.
We're gonna help you.
Take the walkie-talkie.
What do you mean you're gonna help me?
You're going in there and you're making money.
We'll guide you.
No, no.
We're gonna take the walkie-talkie.
You're not guiding me for shit.
No, no, no.
I'm good at this.
You can... No.
Walkie-talkie is a waste of space and we need all the money we can fucking...
Yeah, but I can help you find the monsters so you won't get hurt.
I don't need your help.
But you died like twice because of the monsters.
You're gonna help Ditto.
She needs help.
Okay, okay, Ditto.
You go inside.
I'll use the walkie-talkie.
Okay?
Charge your walkie-talkie.
No, no, no.
You should go inside.
Why are you doing this?
No, no, no.
I'm good at this.
Go skating.
No, no, no.
No, but I can look at the map and I'll tell you there's monsters, Ditto.
Okay, I'll do... I'll do this.
I'll do the... I'll go out the next day.
The next day you guide me but today I guide you, okay?
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I will turn on... Okay, I will turn on the...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, alright.
Ready?
I'm ready.
I'm... Okay.
Alright.
I'll give you the main intent.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll tell you if there's monsters.
Okay, okay.
I believe in you, Ditto.
Yeah, I believe in you too.
Yeah, yeah.
I won't let you die.
I hope you won't lie to me.
Don't worry.
I won't let you die.
Okay, okay.
I saw the bee.
Don't get the bee.
Okay.
I don't understand why he's so... He's so mad.
Wait, there's something to your left.
There's loot.
Is there any monster?
No, no monsters.
No monsters.
I'll let you know there's monsters.
There's a lot of loot though.
Fine.
Okay.
I'm watching.
No monsters.
No loot.
Where is the loot?
No loot or monsters.
Is there any monster?
No, no, no.
No monsters.
See?
I'm doing so well.
I'm such a team player.
I'm helping.
I'm useful.
No monsters.
No loot.
Nice, nice.
There you go.
I opened door.
Okay.
This here?
Yeah, yeah.
No monsters.
No loot.
Wait, what number is that?
You're fine.
Which way?
Which way should we go?
Follow RPR.
Follow him.
Oh, there's loot.
There's loot to your left.
Okay, okay.
I got it.
There's loot.
There's loot there.
Okay, okay.
I got it.
Look at me.
I'm so good.
I'm so good at this game.
Dead end.
Yeah, there's loot there.
Follow RPR.
There's loot.
Wait, what is that?
I'm such a team player.
Oh, I lied.
No loot.
Follow RPR.
There's no monsters.
You're perfectly healthy.
Oh, upstairs loot.
Upstairs loot.
See?
Look at that.
I'm so fucking good at this game.
Is there anything downstairs?
No.
I'm so lost looking at this.
Oh, loot in center.
Loot there.
Go forward.
Top.
Top loot.
Forward.
Follow RPR.
Oh, loot right.
Right side.
Right side loot.
Go back.
Ditto.
Loot.
Wait, did she drop the walkie talkie?
She can't even hear me.
I just realized.
I just realized she can't even hear me because she doesn't have her walkie talkie out.
Can you hear me now?
Yeah, I can hear you.
I can hear you.
Okay, okay, okay.
We need more.
Like, we need more.
Like, 200.
Wait, wait.
There's loot to your...
Wait.
Where are you?
Bring the loot.
I'll come over and bring loot back.
I'll come over.
Okay, okay.
Where am I?
I don't know where the entrance is.
It's not made in time.
Oh.
Where am I?
Is this...
Where is he?
Okay, I'm trying to find the side entrance.
Where am I?
Oh, I see you!
I see you!
I hear you!
Hello?
Here, here.
This way, this way, this way.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll come.
I'll help.
Take it back.
Okay, okay, okay.
Don't worry.
I'll help you too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got my hands full.
Can we come up here?
No, we can't.
Unfortunately.
How do we go back?
Oh, here!
Wait, how do we...?
Where is the shoe?
Wait, I don't think we can...
We have to jump!
Jump!
Wait, can we...?
Eh, eh?
I think...
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, where?
How can we...
Yeah, we're stuck.
How can we get up?
Wait, I think we're stuck.
I think we're stuck.
I think we're...
Wait!
I think I'm stuck!
What?
I think... I think we can come up from here.
Maybe here.
Can we?
This way?
Maybe it's too heavy?
No!
No I can't!
I can't!
We're stuck!
We can't get up!
Okay, we can just bring the loot to the other exit.
But where's the other exit?
I don't remember!
Maybe this way?
I remember, just pick this...
Okay, okay, I got the milk can.
Okay, okay, okay.
But who gets this?
Where are we?
We just follow him.
Oh, I can get...
Wait, where are you?
Can you pick up this flask on the ground?
My hands are full.
No.
We'll go back and get it later.
I'm hands full.
Do you have any empty slots?
No, hands full.
Oh, wait.
I, I, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm, I'm, I'm...
Here.
Okay.
Okay, stop.
No, I won't keep talking.
Oh wait, it's down here.
Are you sure you remember?
Yes, I was just there.
Okay.
Mom?
Oh...
Here.
I'm so scared.
Okay.
Oh, hey.
There's another exit!
Oh, there's another exit!
Nice.
Oh, we're safe.
Okay, okay, we have to go back.
There's still like two items.
There's still two more items we left in the exit.
Wait, did we?
Yeah, we didn't take everything.
Okay, we'll go pick it up.
Yeah, yeah, there was like a big item we didn't pick up.
Oh, can you get the walkie-talkie too?
I think we took everything.
No, no, no, we left the walkie-talkie.
Fuck a walkie-talkie, I don't know.
But that's like... that was $20.
Oh, maybe the ship... yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I see it, I see the ship.
Oh, we can... we can sell the walkie-talkie.
Alright, nice.
It was like... no, we actually left a big item though.
Alright, no, we took it.
No, there was a big item there, wasn't it?
Yeah, but I took it in.
Oh, I had empty slots.
I didn't realize.
She had an empty slot.
I had three empty slots.
So we lost a walkie-talkie for no reason.
Okay, and here's...
So how much money do we make?
Oh, we made $275.
No, $306.
We made it!
There's things inside here.
We did it!
$354.
We need $389.
We need $389 though.
We have enough.
How much more days do we have?
This was our last day.
Only one day.
We gotta go in there then.
This is our last day.
Yeah.
We gotta go in there and pick up one more thing.
Okay, we can sell our walkie-talkies.
Okay.
They're... no, they cost nothing.
I don't think we can sell it.
Oh, okay.
Do you want me to hold...
Okay, I can help.
I'll help.
Wait, but it's 8... 9 p.m.
now.
We can't take the honeycomb.
We can't take the bees.
The bees.
Oh, the bees!
Yeah, the bees!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How much is the bees?
Okay, well, we...
It's like $70 or $80 or something.
Oh, wait, the bees!
Yeah, the bees and we make it.
Wait, giant, giant!
Okay, you can take the bees, but do you know how to do it?
No.
Just pick it up and run to the ship.
Oh, I did.
I'll watch.
The giant, the giant.
Please come here, please come here.
Take the bees, take the bees.
Oh my god.
No, no, the giant's...
The giant's beside the bee.
No, he's not.
He's... he's there, he's there, he's there.
Near the bees.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Watch, watch, watch.
I'm running.
Oh, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
He's running, he's running, he's running.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die!
Did you guys take it?
No!
Ditto got scared!
He can still grab you, he can still grab you here.
We need to take it or we lose.
Our bee...
We...
Ditto got scared and then the giant started chasing us.
I think Ditto died.
No, she's alive.
Oh, she's alive?
Yeah.
Maybe she grabbed the bees.
She didn't.
Did you get the bees, Ditto?
Okay, I'll go get the bees.
No, I don't get it, I don't get it.
We believe in you, RPR!
I can get it.
There's... there's a giant beast alone near the bees.
I can't see it.
Where?
I'm here... I'm here, Ditto.
He's not, he's still alive, he's moving.
Oh no, he's not... oh shit, oh yeah, he's moving.
He's gonna grab the bees.
He's gonna grab it.
I'm gonna dance for victory.
We believe in you.
I believe in him too.
Yeah.
But he didn't grab the bees, he grabbed an item.
I say.
Oh, I say.
Oh, I think...
Fuck.
The ship is leaving.
I think the ship is leaving.
I think he was too late.
You guys are not real!
It doesn't matter if you die to the giant, just pick up the loot or we lose anyway.
There was an ant in there.
The giant was chasing me.
We fell off.
I don't care.
They could have grabbed it when he was chasing.
She could have grabbed it.
One of you died, the other one take the bee.
Yeah, to help.
He was chasing me.
It wasn't my fault.
That guy.
Wait, we need ten dollars.
One body is like ten dollars, right?
No, it's...
One body.
How much is...
That's me!
It was Dino's fault!
I swear!
It wasn't my fault!
It was Dino's fault!
It wasn't my fault, I swear!
You need to die for the company.
No, I didn't!
I didn't die!
You both need to die for the company.
The more money, the better.
Only one of us have...
No!
Only one of us is dead!
There is behind you!
There is behind...
Huh?
What is this?
What do you mean?
Why did I get pound nine?
You think you're safe?
No!
No, don't jump off!
You're gonna make a fool of yourself.
Why are you running?
I'm not running!
Why did you kill us?
Why are you trying to kill us?
Because your body is worth money!
How about your body?
Yeah, well, I got the shovel, don't I?
Yeah, you're gonna die.
Okay, then we're gonna lose.
Fuck it.
Let's lose.
I'm leaving.
No!
I sacrificed my body!
I will sell your body.
It's okay, we will win the game.
We are going to win the game with our bodies.
Are we going to make it?
Yes, because it's 10 dollars.
We just needed 10 dollars.
We just needed that 10 dollars.
Oh, we do.
Blast.
There's more.
If he knows...
Do I sell the walkie-talkie chat?
Can I even sell the walkie-talkie?
Why is he so mad?
Yeah, why is he so mad?
He's so mad today.
I don't understand.
Maybe we make him wake up too early.
Yeah, maybe it's because it's too early.
How much money do we get?
How much do we get?
We should have enough, right?
We're short 25.
25?
What can we sell at 25?
Then what's the point of killing us?
45?
25.
Sell the toy.
If only he could have sold it.
Sold by one engine or one beehive.
The nine of them took but had two fucking whole minutes to take.
But instead they were running.
Because living is more important than making money for the company.
Now we die.
All of us.
We die as a team.
Yeah.
Yeah, we die.
If Uto was here...
If Uto was here, we would have made the money.
We would have made the money if Uto was here.
Listen to me.
If one of you picked up the beehive or the engine...
or the other person is being chased by the giant...
Yeah, dude.
I was being chased by a giant.
Just die for the...
Die for the car, you guys.
It's unbelievable.
Try your best.
Will you always like this?
Yeah.
If I always like this, you are so against it today.
We will try our best.
Holy shit.
After all of that.
That's what you say to me, Dito.
Guys, listen.
I will have a meeting in ten minutes.
You have a meeting?
Yes, I have a meeting in ten minutes.
I'm calling it here.
It's a GG.
So we're done here.
Are we finally done?
We did it.
Are we finally done with this culture?
Yay.
Next time, next time...
Next time...
Hey, we're totally okay.
Next time, Uto will be here, guys.
Oh my god.
Yay.
I'm free.
From this pill.
Yay.
Oh my god.
I thought it was never going to end.
I thought it was going to separate here from...
I had a great time, guys.
It was a great...
I had a great time playing with all of you.
Yeah, great time.
This was so fun.
Yeah, thank you.
We were so...
We had a lot of fun.
Yeah.
I learned so much.
I learned so much working in this company.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you guys definitely...
You did so much work.
Yeah.
Yeah, you guys did so much work.
I'm really happy to working with you up here.
It's so nice.
Yeah, I'm really happy to work with you up here.
I'm really happy to work with you guys up here.
Oh, I'm so happy to work with you.
You are great leader.
It's such a nice opportunity.
I was so happy...
Like if I could compare like working with you guys to anything, it's almost like playing Wii 9 in League of Legends.
You are a great leader.
Yeah.
Great boss.
Good boss.
I can't handle you guys.
Even though you were the laziest employee, we think you were the best se- I'm the laziest!
Yeah.
Did you see how much money I made us every run?
You bought a toilet with my hard earned money!
You bought a toilet!
I was just reading the game stats!
You bought a toilet with my money!
I was explaining what we thought.
Yeah, I just read what the game said.
You bought a fucking toilet!
You could have bought anything else!
A poop box and a toilet!
It was a good poop box, I had a good time.
You could have bought a stun gun, a shovel, anything!
I bought walkie talkies!
As I'm making money for you to survive, you guys are planning to kill me in front of the main entrance with stop signs?
How are you real?
Why are you so mad?
We were just talking!
It was like girl talk, right?
It was girl talk.
I was making so much money and then I died to a brat!
I went to the dorm and I got an injection that slaps my neck in half!
And then I expected you guys to see what you guys are doing!
Maybe you guys are making money, but no!
You guys are standing at the door and saying how you got enough of me!
We also make money!
Yeah, we brought money back!
You are making money for me, you are trying to murder me, you are planning to kill me!
If you didn't die, we could have made more money!
If I didn't die you would have killed me!
No, we wouldn't.
We were doing girl talk.
We wouldn't.
We were just talking.
You wouldn't understand.
You don't understand girl talk.
Sometimes we just say we were joking.
Yeah, we were like JK.
If you were respecting us earlier, you could tell they don't know.
We were like, okay, let's pretend we're gonna kill him.
It'll be so funny if we pretend, right?
Yeah.
We're gonna scare him.
You guys really... after years of knowing you guys, you guys think I believe anything that comes out of your mouth?
I don't.
Ever.
It's dumb and dumber, I hear from them.
Dumb and dumber.
If Uto was here too, he wouldn't yell at us.
If Uto was here, he wouldn't yell at us.
Yeah, cause Uto's an actual angel that would try to get us out of this mess.
This godforsaken planet.
While you two are sabotaging my hard fucking work.
If only Uto was here.
This is insane.
I feel 20 years older after this.
It's not even funny.
I had a great time, guys.
Someone clicked this whole thing, bro.
The descent into madness.
I start off as a normal working employee, and as we keep going, I become a fucking villain, bro.
You turn me into the fucking Joker in like an hour.
You don't have to be this mad, just come down, come down, come down.
Kill him.
You can get HR in here.
It's not good for your health, you know?
Yeah, it's not good.
You're aging.
You're too mad.
You're getting older.
You need to calm down.
The stress isn't good for you.
Your blood pressure is rising.
You gotta calm down.
I'm only 27!
It's not good for you.
See, I told you the stress isn't good for you right now.
The stress isn't good for you.
You will get older faster.
Yeah, you'll get older faster.
You could put a perfectly healthy man into a mental institution.
In two hours.
GG, Scott.
I'm out of luck.
Yay!
Hey, shut...
I'm taking the bag off!
I'm done.
He's done.
Oh my God.
I had a great time, guys.
Next time, I will...
I will definitely check with Jody next time.
Next time.
Next time, if Uto joins and she's as bad as you guys, I will jump off the f-cking ship as we start playing every single time.
I swear to God.
Why would you do that?
Uto better not be...
No.
...corrupt by you two f-cking demons.
No, we won't.
We're not demons.
We're angels.
She's cheating.
She's good like us.
Yeah, she's good just like you!
Like us.
You're not good!
We're good people!
You're evil!
We're good people, we made us money!
You're two demons born of hell!
Both of you!
We'll be fine!
We'll be okay!
We'll be okay, guys!
I had...
Save me!
You know, guys, I had a great time.
Yeah, me too.
It was great!
It was amazing time.
It was great playing with you two.
So much fun!
It was so fun, guys!
So fucking fun!
It was so fun!
Yeah, see?
You thought it was fun!
See?
So fun!
Yeah, great fun!
Here, do you need a hug?
Do you need a hug?
I'm going to Altifor in five seconds.
Say your last words right now.
You were...
You were a great leader, Artie.
You were the greatest employee.
I didn't say that!
She said that!
What did she say?
I didn't say anything!
You are the greatest employee.
Employee?
I'm an employee?
Yeah.
Yeah, you are paid to dance for sure.
You are a fucking part-timer!
You are a great partner.
I said you were great.
You are our great partner.
Yeah.
Can we self-destruct this fucking shit?
GG's, guys!
GG's!
I had a good time.
I'll see you guys next time.
With Uto this time.
Yeah, it was a good game, guys.
Good game!
I can't wait for another one of these.
Yay!
Bye-bye, guys.
Goodbye.
Bye!
Guys, I think I...
I had a great time, everybody.
Guys, you heard RPO.
You had a great time.
I am saying the entire stream since 3 am, and I don't regret one bit.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I think we had good teamwork.
We worked really well together.
Chat.
What do you mean?
Guys, I think we had a good time together.
I think we had a great time.
I still can't believe... I still can't believe... Ditto organized this collab and she forgot to tell Uto the time.
I thought that was the funniest shit.
Because she told me and RPR but then she forgot to tell Uto.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I had a great time.
This was great.
It was good teamwork.
I think we... I think we had really good teamwork.
Rose, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got to tell him but it was hilarious.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Without us, RPR wouldn't be able to move the money.
Ditto and I got all the money to the ship.
Wait.
What are you guys talking about?
We moved all the money to the ship.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Next week... By the way, next week is going to be a little bit...
I don't... Actually, I'm trying to remember what we have next week.
Alright.
Challenger Circuit.
ALGS Challenger Circuit is like semi-confirmed.
I will be participating in the Challenger Circuit.
I think it's like Saturday, Sunday, Monday.
If you make it to the finals.
So mostly it may be just Saturday.
So I will be doing that with Nice Wig and Tempo.
So we're just waiting on Wig to like sign us up.
But he's like... He's going to be signing us up.
And he said it's going to be on the 22nd, I think.
22nd... Or was it 23rd?
I don't remember.
It's like...
I don't... Let me... Wait.
I actually don't remember.
Whichever date Challenger Circuit starts next week.
But...
We're going to be doing ALGS Challenger Circuit with Nice Wig and Tempo next week.
I don't remember if it was like Saturday, Sunday, or Monday.
Oh!
And also...
I'm trying to remember any other updates I have to give you guys.
But I think that's really...
I got like so many...
I got like invites to some like...
Another...
Like a turn...
Lots of tournaments recently.
So like...
To the point where I actually have to like...
Pick and choose what to participate.
Because there's like a lot of tournament invites.
And I actually had to...
For the first time, I actually had to decline a tournament.
It was a tournament because I just had too much going on.
So it's crazy!
I actually had to decline a tournament off.
Like a tournament invite.
It's supposed to be like a...
Another PAL World tournament.
But it's just like...
I'm gonna...
I have like Apex stuff going on next week.
I can't do both.
But yeah!
Other than that, I think that is really...
That is really the only updates I have for you guys.
I am so...
I'm so tired.
I took like a little nap before the stream.
Because I was like...
Oh my god.
Okay.
El Reno originally...
We were supposed to do 5pm PST.
But then...
Because like for RPR, he's still in...
He's still in EU.
So...
We had to change the time.
So at first, like we suggested 8am PST.
And I was like...
No!
Because I was like...
I can stay up.
But I cannot wake up Saturday.
So I was like...
Yeah, no.
Not 8am.
8am.
I cannot do 8am.
So we settled on like 1am because I was like...
I can't.
Guys.
1am is too much.
Like...
I'm not wondering.
8am is too much.
I cannot do mornings.
I can only...
I can only stay up.
I can only stay up until like 3am...
Like 3am to 4am.
I cannot wake up at 8am.
So we settled on 1am.
1am.
Anyway guys, I'm gonna call it here everybody.
Oh my god, I didn't even realize my music was off.
My BGM was off.
But I'm gonna call it here.
I hope you guys had a great time.
For everybody in NA that stayed up.
Now you know how the dragoons on the other side of the world feels like.
It's your turn.
It was your turn to stay up.
It's your turn now, dragoons and NA.
To stay up for D-Gen hours.
Anyway everybody, as always everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!